chanting death to the dictator in a
school takes bravery so does posting the
video online
the internet in Iran has been throttled
and protesters have been beaten up shot
at abducted
human rights groups say there have been
hundreds of deaths men women and
children
the protesters are adapting the Sky News
analysis is found by posting shorter
clips and deliberately blurring
identities a high-stakes game of cats
and mouse with the authorities the
protesters the youth adapt for example
whenever there is a little bit of
Internet they they try to send the
footages outside
when footages are not possible they try
to leave voice messages text messages
about what's going on there's a kind of
an organic
Grassroots level documentation of what's
Happening
yeah
previously it took more than 24 hours
for the government to impose a
nation-scale information blackout during
the 2019 protests
but now authorities can restrict access
much more quickly and with much greater
Precision if you look at this graph you
can see the Peaks and troughs of when
data is blocked and at its lowest you
can see there's basically nothing
Sky News has been monitoring video clips
since the start of the protests
many of those videos are short this
makes them easier to send to Iranians
abroad who can share the post beyond the
reach of Iranian controls and reach more
people
and despite all those restrictions
exclusive data from talk Walker a social
analytics company reveals that the
hashtag Masa amini has been posted more
than 65 million times across the
internet since her death in
mid-september
what we're seeing here actually is the
power of social media in a very very
dramatic way to really
um encourage sort of these sort of
cellular organization of the country and
there's a lot of CopyCat obviously going
along but it's it's been quite
interesting how they've organized
themselves
women life liberty they chant the
smartphone is a vital tool in that cause
Tom Cheshire Sky News